the capital of Minas Jedis doesn't stop
moving to the sound of campaigning
this is Brazil's most significant
Battleground state where leftist
candidate Lula da Silva has a very slim
lead
Barbara Ravena wants the incumbent
president Jade bolsonaro out of office
and she's appealing to women who make up
more than half the voters and
yeah bolsonaro is a misogynist and
sexist man he'd made offensive comments
to female journalists to women he said
that women should earn less because they
get pregnant so if bolsonaro wins women
lose
all candidates are basically preaching
to the converted while Lula is here
bolsonaro's wife is nearby also talking
to women and other supporters of the
conservative movement but even so
they're going to make their presence
felt and to show their strengths
Ministry is regarded as a micro sample
of the Brazilian electorate and at this
busy Watering Hole politics is on
everyone's lips
no we've never had anything like this
kind of polarization in Brazil before
bolsonaro is my man I'm not going to
vote for a former convict you have to be
crazy to vote for Lula
in this upper middle class neighborhood
bolsonaro supporters sing the national
anthem dressed in the Brazilian flag in
line with their candidates nationalist
stance
bolsonaro is totally pro-family how can
someone who supports the family be
against women there's no way
in rural brumadino voters tend to
support Lula but abstention is high
especially among the poor who often
can't afford the bus to go to vote I
think one of the reasons why Lula is
spending a lot of time in his rallies in
minus is his lack is exactly to try to
make those voters go to vote
if this race is as tight as most predict
every single vote will count especially
here in Minas Jedis where no Brazilian
president has ever won without winning
the state
to see a Newman Al Jazeera brumadino
Brazil